Stephen that doesn't matter what you
think it's just a book ha
tell it to the internet well you stole
my opening joke I was like god I just
wish I beat you half the Internet what
the watch is episode um this is open
yeah they would probably watch it and
criticize it this is of course it would
go that route protectable Oh doesn't
artist you can't do anything good
themselves yeah well that's it up as
episodes okay a bunch of fluff that was
good as somebody obviously zombies Star
Trek holodeck episode you know I was
either either one out of the one where
data asks the holodeck to create a an
adversary as good as him and so creates
a Moriarty that can take control of the
fucking ship or the one where Worf ends
up going into the Old West and the
program breaks down they they really
liked fucking around with the holodeck
yeah well no that was like my one I mean
like my one major promise starts at
next-generation it's like holodeck no no
there be no journeying space or anything
it's like you see what we do with our
fucking iPhones I mean that that's an i
but this is a good room there's no
anything i look at internet porn and
tell me that anybody everyone will be in
the holodeck you would go to that
holodeck and you you wouldn't leave no
no one would
Oh anywho uh I kind of thought they were
gonna do more with that honestly uh sort
of making Akane that he wasn't where he
would any others on what reality was
inside to do this yeah I mean instantly
it's like I you told me not to do what
you want so I would have said fine don't
disappear yeah or honest oh no don't do
what I don't why I'm sorry reverse
psychology way you can oh maybe it can
read is mine but this brings up another
thing all of these things like like Star
Trek in the holodeck and then the cloud
room or whatever it is you think there
would be a safety feature built into
these things so that you Korean can't
create something that could fucking kill
you well with this we he doesn't know
how it works and then the last one I
mean it really did almost kind of like
consume every state
there were only didn't know what reality
was and stuff so I guess we kind of got
that already so I guess I'm not sad they
didn't go there I'm just saying like we
live in like a world now where we have
to like put safety railings around
everything and 12 different warnings and
like and that's why it's true
I just know but that's like alien
technology and stuff and they don't even
know how it works they don't know how
millions then they don't have kids
no no remember it's half human have gem
whatever that's what's even they needed
they needed in a hospital to get off
like child like safety cap in that room
like I don't because they don't I only
know how it works and he doesn't timely
know how it works I I buy it okay I
think it's fine fucking aliens in there
you know their clown rooms they're just
screwing your head killing baby oh you
know I should point out by the way that
uh Wikipedia said this was the next
episode Amazon doesn't say it in fact
Amazon has like three other it like the
next two or three episodes are not in
Amazon season two so I'm just gonna go
by the Wikipedia cows nose drives me
nuts because the next one in the Amazon
list said the message and I'm like that
yeah I like that yeah yeah I'm like but
it it's one of those things where it's
like a lot of people are saying you
gotta watch this in the right order like
people are trying to send me lists and
stuff like that so it's kind of fair
enough because the show obviously you
kind of want find out things in order um
live too soon
yeah so so I'm going by the Wikipedia
one if for some reason that's not right
I'm sure people will tell me um but yeah
this was the next one the Wikipedia list
um actually none of them are right it
turns out that the next episode is a
secret episode that you can only see on
youtube scrambled and backwards gonna
cow um but yeah I thought this was AI
mean introduces obviously a good message
which is don't sneeze in the middle of
be log leave the messages always tell
the truth to your possible girlfriend or
else you will get destroyed by your own
cloud burn
always tell the truth that you like the
ending to a book um yeah that what you
think of that do you think that's a
little bit cuz they're obviously
building up like he's gonna tell her
that he likes her
stay says he likes the ending to the
book and I'm kinda like okay um like I
actually took that at face value that
that's what the but she said I know
honey was talking no she said I know you
like me I know you have feelings for her
I know that like she says all well okay
okay but the first step is honesty and
he was lying about himself because he
was afraid of what she was going to
think um and that is not a good way to
start a relationship so I guess so this
is like the first step to admitting like
you know her stuff okay um
baby steps maybe distance um yeah I like
the egg fucking anything this day and
age that can teach look you can like
something you can not like something
disagree it makes the conversation more
interesting if that's really what you
think will become the most unpopular
episode reviewed on the other but you
know what thank God do you know what
because we need people to stand up for
this stuff that is not really even that
picket I love it like I will get like
messages on my public page like well I
liked goosebumps or some random more
like good right I liked Mamma Mia what
do you have to say about that
enjoy yeah I did what do you want me to
say
I don't everyone thought like cuz I met
Chris Duckman a dumb Oh wizard world I
still get that which is about yeah
everyone's like oh you're gonna get in a
fight about sighs you know he likes
signs like signs add up like every week
somebody sends a baby did you save this
stuck my review on signs soon I'm like I
don't care that's like fine he can find
you I can only ones I don't have to
agree with him like he does not have to
agree with me ya know I mean I don't
like it he's always compromised and say
that we're right and he's wrong
absolutely that's the way it works um
but no it's uh it's definitely one of
those things where it's here's another
thing I really like to in this episode
that I I don't know there's something
about it cuz we're adults and we talk
about stuff we're really passionate
about and we like dislike and stuff like
you talked about her critique of the nd
well no no I like I've always liked
hearing younger people talk about
creative stuff that they really enjoy
and with a legitimate love that
lucky to necessarily bitch about
something to really talk about because
they really care and between the two of
them you know you just you guys are both
ends like he liked sorry the simpler
stuff and the stuff about the cake and
stuff and she wanted a more progressive
ending that's gonna say a lot more dear
my dear my moves are Jurassic world
sibling rivalry where he just went on
this fucking rant about I'm just saying
oh no I at the beginning when she was
talking like shit this reminds me a lot
this is I think more particularly me but
uh but but you can go on about certain
stuff to that's like you know Wow okay I
mean I think not every once in a while
there's something that I'm just like
fuck this but um but yeah I think it's
something where it's good to show you
can be open about it but at the same
time it also like you say show sort of
this baby step phase taking to you know
open up more to her and stuff um I I I
think the only reason I was kinda hoping
it go this other route of like him kinda
getting stuck in the room again even
though would be repetitive is that I
know there's something I like about he
can he can so easily get lost in that
room and again that sort of feeds into
like the internet thing the iPhone thing
the digital realm where it's you can so
easily get lost in this world and just
like this is your new reality you know
and it that's not what reality is and
you're building yourself up for
disappointment it's not healthy um well
I like the setup too I mean when the
other evil Connie broke down when he
said I just want to do what you want
cuz that's exactly what he was doing
yeah um so but again we we did kind of
do that already and it's like why repeat
it you know instead we sort have this
nicer episode I mean it was fine I mean
as a woman I didn't do it I'm like oh
it's the Star Trek next gen Ed's with
the holodeck you know honestly I mean it
applies to any sort of thing like that
West world or even Jurassic Park where
yeah a theme park concept breaks down or
something you know but um that was
pretty good it's always about the
execution
I thought the execution was fine I guess
I I don't know the usual like you can
look at those clouds right no it's more
it what's going on instead the really
cool episode with pearls kind of
backstory there with Rose I'm like
alright this is fun
like the clouds are nice but what the
fuck was going on they're letting a kid
yeah like two or three episodes of major
like story I mean it is I think in do
you want I know but I want more um it's
a good let me put you this way
it's a fucking good thing because I
means I'm getting fucking addicted to
this show hmm so I mean it's a good
problem to have but that's the thing I'm
like fluff episode no little fluff cloud
fluff um no I liked it and uh I feel
like Connie's getting a I feel like
she's getting even more of a character I
maybe you can know she does she has a
character I mean she she definitely had
a character before she's a little shy
and a bit of a bookworm and stuff but
again I think that was her character no
no a bunch of acara no no but I will say
this I'm because all the people that
like I've known the start off kind of
shy and they get to know more it's this
does kind of happen I think it's okay
where it's like where would know where
they open up more and they talk more
than suffice I'm not saying that like I
found her earlier episodes insufferable
is actually the opposite I thought they
were really cute together so waters ever
Knoll on the other hand yeah uh but um
actually we so need to get those two
together yeah now there's the couple
there's the true couple that's hiding
there I think there would be an
extraordinarily dangerous idea like some
key master gatekeeper shit going on
there um yeah Jonathan I mean it's it's
fine it's it's cute it has a good
message um and you know again it's done
pretty it's done through the story in
the emotions and stuff like that um and
uh ya know I definitely like it yeah
destinies end by the way sounds like it
should be some like late 90s dance group
or something you know it the other the
other detail they added on there I I
forgot about a Prada when he's done
reading Destiny's end I love that little
sigh cuz that's the side you always get
when you finish a big book TIFF Oh like
whether it's good bad or whatever you're
just like
oh I like it you finished especially
those big massive ones
um when if you read a big massive book
in your entire life
junk leases biographies pretty big well
um so ya know I gives a good episode fun
stuff um anything else name one other
big massive book you've read Where's
Waldo it's a lot going on the netbook I
still can't believe it took you three
months you know what there's a lot to
look at there are so many stories going
on in those books you just have to see
the Mafia just for Waldo I look for the
stories going on every one of those
people has a story going on and again
it's done visually not through a bunch
of yapping that's what a bunch of words
use come get him in it's all a metaphor
for losing your soul right now actually
press so I probably could do like a
really big about somewhere topple do
they do that it was her nerve or zog's
Waldo or something I thought it was I
thought there was a video on YouTube or
something it was like what the German
eggs I was like dis Vonda what does it
mean it was like ridiculous is like
searching through the pictures and I
swear I saw that if not I know what
we're doing as an XK yeah oh that's
pretty funny uh so that's about it we'll
see in the next one later